[Musik]
dies ist die geschichte eines der
größten korruptionsskandale aller zeiten
ein betrug der eines der ersten länder
der welt schätzungsweise sein gesamtes
bruttoinlandsprodukt gekostet hat die
wirtschaftsleistung aller seiner über 30
millionen einwohner eines ganzen jahres
einfach so pum verzockt eine geschichte
die ohne zutaten wie grenzenlose
erwartungen ungezügelte gier und
finanztechnische winkelzüge beim
länderrisiko nicht möglich gewesen wäre
was wir damit meinen keine angst am ende
dieses videos was du genau verstehen wie
es in diesen aufstrebenden afrikanischen
land zu solch einem epochalen desaster
kommen konnte denn heute geht es bei
visual politik um die thunfisch bonds
von mosambik und glaubt mehr so
merkwürdig das alles klingt zum
mitreißend ist diese ganze geschichte
also schon mal dich an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für afrika den vergessenen kontinent die
letzte region der welt die sich der
moderne angeschlossen hat waren die
ersten beiden jahrzehnte des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts eine
beeindruckende erfolgsgeschichte die
armut ging drastisch zurück und die
meisten afrikanischen volkswirtschaften
begangen zu wachsen plötzlich führte die
nachfrage nach infrastruktur und
projekten aller art dazu dass viele
afrikanische regierungen auf der suche
nach liquidität und investitionen die
finanzmärkte stimmten diese hießen sie
euphorisch willkommen und öffneten ihre
arme ganz weit in der illusion einen
schönen batzen dieser riesigen
wohlstands welle abzubekommen und wisst
ihr was der protagonist unseres videos
muss am weg war nicht nur eines der
länder welche der focus mit
riesenschritten entgegen halten sondern
wurde zu einer der reichsten
volkswirtschaften des ganzen kontinents
institutionelle reformen ausländische
investitionen tourismus und die
entdeckung riesiger gasfelder im kuba
flussbecken an der nordküste mosambiks
an der grenze zu tansania schien ein
vielversprechendes bild zu zeichnen im
ersten jahrzehnt dieses jahrhunderts lag
das wirtschaftswachstum mosambiks bei
und sieben prozent pro jahr und das
bevor mit der ausbeutung eines der
größten erdgasvorkommen der welt
begonnen wurde derweil eine vorstellung
davon zu geben während das volumen der
muss amerikanischen wirtschaft im jahr
2010 nur etwa zehn milliarden dollar
betrug ging der ids davon aus dass es
bis 2021 30 milliarden dollar erreichen
und bis 2025 gar sage und schreibe 75
milliarden dollar übersteigen würde das
wäre eine verdreifachung innerhalb von
zehn jahren und eine ver siebeneinhalb
wochen innerhalb von 15 jahren klar mit
30 675 milliarden dollar auf 30
millionen einwohner bibel es ein immer
noch sehr armes land aber die erwartete
entwicklung war kolossal
und wir alle wissen ja gefühlsmäßig
nehmen menschen die veränderungen viel
stärker war als den status quo eine
stagnation selbst auf hohem niveau kann
unsere gemüter stärker betrieben als
wachstum von einem sehr niedrigen
ausgangspunkt aus die realität in
mosambik sei jedoch ganz anders aus im
jahr 2021 wird die wirtschaft des
südamerikanischen landes statt der
prognostizierten 30 milliarden weniger
als 16 milliarden dollar groß sein und
obwohl sich die lage verbessern soll
werden die zahlen immer noch weitere den
ursprünglichen prognosen zurückbleiben
und auch in den letzten jahren verlief
die entwicklung ganz anders als erwartet
statt guter nachrichten musste das land
einen zahlungsausfall eine enorme
haushalts anpassung und kapitalflucht
verkraften die frage die uns allen unter
den nägeln brennt lautet daher ganz klar
was zum teufel ist passiert dass die
ursprünglichen projektion so krass
falsch lagen wie so sieht die realität
wirklich ganz anders aus als alle
experten vorhergesagt haben
waren das alles amateure die einfach ins
blaue hinein geschossen haben nein ganz
und gar nicht das land hatte wirklich
das potenzial das sie vorausgesagt haben
und es hätte es wirklich nutzen können
das schicksal muss am wegs könnte heute
ganz anders aussehen wenn ja wenn es
nicht zu einer ganz bestimmten
finanzoperationen bekommen wäre einer
list welche die wirtschaft dieses landes
in einen schrecklichen albtraum gestürzt
hat und von dieser tragischen und
lehrreichen geschichte wäre ich euch
heute erzählen zuvor möchte ich euch
jedoch darauf hinweisen dass ihr die
arbeit von visual politik.de ist aktiv
durch eine spende unterstützen könnt ihr
wisst ja diese videos drehen ist keine
leichte arbeit und eure spenden bereiten
uns nicht nur eine riesenfreude sondern
helfen uns auch unabhängig zu bleiben
und die zahl und qualität unserer videos
zu steigern jeder euro wird den
zukünftigen videos für euch reinvestiert
den link zum spenden findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video und es
würde uns sehr freuen wenn du das video
jetzt für eine kleine spende posieren
würdest vielen dank so und jetzt machen
wir uns auf eine reise in den südosten
des afrikanischen kontinents in ein land
mit paradiesischen traumstränden westen
große hoffnungen und träume durch
großbanken politiker und skrupellose
geschäftsleute zerquetscht wurden wie
eine überreife mango
das vergiftete geschenk der tun für
sport man schrieb das jahr 2010 und die
dinge liefen gut für mosambik die
wirtschaft des landes begonnen sich zu
entwickeln um die gasfelder versprachen
gewinne ohne ende zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt in jedem jahr fanden jedoch
eine reihe von treffen und
vereinbarungen statt welche die zukunft
des landes mehr als ein jahrzehnt regen
sollten führungskräfte von priv invest
einem bekannten französischen
libanesischen schiffbauunternehmen
unterbreiteten gemeinsame top manager
der schweizer bank für die zwischen
hochrangigen regierungsvertretern des
afrikanischen landes einen geschäfts
vorschlag
zu dieser zeit waren die märkte von den
hohen renditen amerikanischer anleihen
begeistert und mosambik würde bald seine
riesigen vorkommen an fossilen
brennstoffen ausbeuten warum also warten
das land könnte eine riesige menge an
anleihen ausgeben um die entwicklung
neuer produktiver sektoren zu
finanzieren schließlich würde man aus
den erdgas einnahmen bald alle
rechnungen bezahlen können nur gesagt
getan gemeinsam mit der russischen bank
vtb machten sich alle parteien an die
arbeit um eine große fischerei industrie
im land aufzubauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das problem wenn das problem ist dass
die interessen mosambik selbst bei
diesem geschäft nie berücksichtigt
wurden in den folgenden drei jahren
gründete die regierung drei staatliche
unternehmen nehmen muss am bug asset
management und pro indigos
überraschenderweise waren die beiden
hauptaktionäre oder direkten eigentümer
das verteidigungsministerium und der
geheimdienst ja das ist richtig die rede
ist noch immer von fischereiunternehmen
und der hauptaktionäre waren das
verteidigungsministerium und der
geheimdienst doktor will hätte es sich
nicht besser ausdenken können oder wien
geht es nicht das bild von haien mit
laser durch den kopf nun tatsache ist
dass die schweizer bank credit suisse
und die russische vtb zwischen 2013 und
2014 eine finanzierungsrunde organisiert
haben um all diese projekte
voranzubringen ob dr wilhelm and laser
darunter waren konnten wir auch durch
ausgiebige recherchen nicht mit aller
sicherheit feststellen wenn dann wäre
die sie ohnehin ein unterfangen unter
aller strengster geheimhaltung gewesen
und ihr wisst ja dass wir keine probleme
haben uns mit putin erdogan oder weniger
anzulegen aber bei dr evil ist schluss
nein das geht selbst uns zu weit
[Musik]
okay was wir aber herausgefunden haben
insgesamt ging es bei der finanzierung
darum über zwei milliarden dollar zu
beschaffen auf den ersten blick
vielleicht ein betrag der uns klein
erscheinen mag bis wir bedenken dass
dies was 15 prozent des gesamten bip des
landes und mehr als 20 prozent der
gesamten auslandsforderungen
zwei milliarden dollar stand fast die
hälfte aus anleihen die auf dem
internationalen markt mit einer rendite
von 8,5 prozent platziert wurden eine
rentabilität die sich so einem riesigen
erfurt machte die nachfrage überstieg
das angebot um ein vielfaches die rede
ist von nichts geringerem als dem
berühmt-berüchtigten thunfisch anleihen
in wirklichkeit handelte es sich jedoch
um eine riesige list um eines der
ärmsten länder der welt bis auf die
knochen zu schröpfen
[Musik]
ein unterfangen bei dem sich alle
akteure noch mal selbst an
niederträchtigkeit übertroffen haben
doktor evil ausgenommen sie nutzten die
tatsache aus dass investitionen afrika
gerade extrem in mode waren um diese
bizarre operation durchzuführen
die beiden banken die das geschäft
abwickelten kassierten fast 200
millionen dollar an band gebühren und
provisionen das bedeutet das dass zehn
trotzdem der gesamten finanzierung an
die banken gingen die das geschäft
abgewickelt haben völlig
unverhältnismäßig
[Musik]
darüber hinaus waren die prospekte und
machbarkeitsstudien reiste science
fiction so wurde den internationalen
investoren zum beispiel erzählt dass die
muss amerikanischen fischer pro jahr
etwa
200.000 tonnen thunfisch wangen würden
wirklichkeit beliefen sich die fänge
einheimischer plus ausländischer
schlüssel im jahr 2013 nach angaben der
nationalen fischereibehörde auf nur 6000
tonnen außerdem basierten die
geschätzten einnahmen auf den verkauf
von thunfisch zu mehr als 10.000 dollar
pro tonne einem völlig ohne angemessenen
preis auf dem großhandelsmarkt aber
wisst ihr was das alles interessierte
damals niemanden was du in afrika zu
investieren war der letzte schrei warum
sollte man da in die langweiligen
details eintauchen wer ist schon gerne
das kleingedruckte geld unter den
investoren befanden sich auch so
wichtige unternehmen wie die
portugiesische handelsbank und die
united bank for africa
[Musik]
tatsache ist jedoch dass letztlich alle
prächtig daran verdient haben außerdem
mosambikaner selbst die emittierenden
banken kassierten 200 millionen dollar
das militär gab den großteil erhaltenen
gelder nicht für fischerboote sondern
für kriegsschiffe aus aber nicht einfach
so das unternehmen von dem die schiffe
gekauft wurden verkaufte sie zu einem
erheblichen aufschlag kickback inklusive
auf diese weise wurden natürlich auch
die politiker nicht außen vor gelassen
ferrari rolls royces luxus bmw es sogar
ein flugzeug aus frankreich das mit 7400
flaschen wein beladen war wurden
dokumentiert und vor allem floss viel
viel bargeld insgesamt wurden die summen
die direkt in bestechungsgelder flossen
bei prüfungen auf bis zu 500 millionen
dollar geschätzt die thunfisch
unternehmen wurde nicht gegründet um
gewinn zu erwirtschaften sondern als
pures betitelt und nico in form des
amerikanischen volks so richtig
abzumelden
[Musik]
aber moment mal sind internationale
banken wie die credit suisse nicht an
bestimmte ethik standards gebunden
schließlich müssten vor allem
unternehmen die in den usa geschäfte
machen wollen damit rechnen von den
us-behörden haftbar gemacht zu werden
und zwar für korruptionsfälle weltweit
firmen wie ist ihnen dies könnte von
einem ganoven liedchen singen nun die
idee der banker war dass die zukünftigen
gas gewinne die durch den raub
entstandene lücke im staatshaushalt
schon ausgleichen würden und so niemand
etwas bemerken würde die schulden wurden
also geheim gehalten und nicht in den
staatshaushalt aufgenommen sie wurden
als versteckte schulden deklariert ja
und als die einnahmen aus dem gasexport
ausblieben begann das ganze kartenhaus
einzustürzen und für die credit suisse
wächst dieser skandal gerade jetzt zu
einem riesenproblem heran aufgepasst
das mega debakel
als das wall street journal 2016 alle
details über die entstandenen schulden
veröffentlichte war die hysterie groß
internationale geber länder und der iwf
selbst stoppen sofort ihre beiträge an
mosambik was die stars einnahmen
einbrechen ließ das wiederum führte dazu
dass die regierung nicht in der lage war
ihre rechnungen zu bezahlen
dies löste eine schreckliche lawine aus
mosambik legte einen spektakulären
zahlungsausfall und der zusammenbruch
der öffentlichen ausgaben führte
geradewegs in eine wirtschaftskrise
ungeheuren ausmaßes welche eine massive
kapitalflucht die abwertung der währung
nach sich zog die auslandsschulden
wurden sind das arme land unbezahlbar
das bip-wachstum brach ein die
arbeitslosigkeit schoss in die höhe und
fast zwei millionen menschen fielen
unter die armutsgrenze
die thunfisch anleihen waren zu einer
lebensbedrohlichen belastung geworden
die schuldenlast hat sich im verhältnis
zu den staatseinnahmen mehr als
versechsfacht
nach berechnungen des center for public
integrity in mosambik und dass christian
mit hessen institut in norwegen belaufen
sich die gesamtwirtschaftlichen kosten
auch über 11 milliarden dollar was den
gesamten bruttoinlandsprodukt des landes
im jahr 2016 entspricht eine katastrophe
mit der das land auf jahre hinaus
gestraft sein wird und die auffällig für
die swiss zu einem alptraum geworden ist
wir sprechen hier über eine bank in der
in letzter zeit an skandalen wirklich
kein mangel hersteller muss am weg
leidet unter dem skandal um die
thunfisch anleihen der credit suisse die
schweizer bank wurde zu einer geldstrafe
von
475 millionen dollar verurteilt
die vorstellungen das ist für die credit
suisse vorbei ist ist völlig falsch es
gibt derzeit eine menge
rechtsstreitigkeiten vor den englischen
gerichten und das wird nicht aufhören
wenn überhaupt werden sie sich immer
mehr ausweiten natascha harrison
geschäftsführende partnerin von boris
schiller flex der us-kanzlei welche die
schweizer bank im namen mehrerer
gläubiger verklagt hat
diese ganze operation wird jetzt vor
gericht auseinander genommen aber der
schaden ist bereits angerichtet
das zusammenspiel von großbanken
politikern und skrupellosen
geschäftsleute sowie die mangelnde
aufmerksamkeit internationaler
investoren haben in einem der ärmsten
länder der welt eine riesige katastrophe
verursacht das ist also wie traurige
geschichte der verfluchten thunfisch
anleihen denke also auch drew daran auf
die details zu achten hüte dich vor
mangel an transparenz und
rechtssicherheit lass dich dich zum
versprechen leichter und angeblich
sorgenfreie gewinne locken denn eine
solche investition künftig am ende in
einen riesigen alptraum verwandeln aber
jetzt bist du dran
glaubst du dass mosambik mit der
rückzahlung dieser riesigen schulden von
insgesamt mehr als vier milliarden
dollar plus zinsen allein gelassen
werden sollte wie könnte diese art von
betrug in zukunft verhindert werden und
kennst du andere beispiele für derartige
skrupellosen verschwörungen von politik
und großkapital durch welche das volk
ausgeraubt werden soll wie immer sind
auf eure meinung zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat fast ja
unterstützt unsere arbeit bitte mit
einer kleinen spende werden link in der
beschreibung geht es auch ein like teil
das video mit euren freunden und
vergesslich das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
und zu guter letzt möchten wir uns bei
unseren freunden von values cool
bedanken mit der hilfe dieses video
entstanden ist macht es gut und bis bald
[Musik]